and i'm right here with my boy bootleg
cab
on hot 975 baby in vegas act like you're
not right man we're here with
tech9cat.com exactly another tour tech
in the books man hostile takeover
brother how's it been this is gonna be
the longest one man i was 90 cities nah
they moved it to 95 cities and uh
in 104 days man that's crazy
by the time i'm get done with this i'm
gonna be like this skinny no voice no
nothing but what i'm saying what is your
physical like regimen before you go on
tour because i i i could imagine that be
this is truly exhausting it's the show
itself that is a workout it's making me
lose weight all right i was almost 200
pounds before this started now i'm going
down down down down down you know indeed
yeah man so this is only show 20 out of
95.
so um
you got machine gun kelly along with you
this time gun kelly man hardcore
performer man you know i'm sizzling
hardcore lyricist he's the best one i
ever had on tour with me to go on before
me like ooh i gotta come with it that's
what i'm saying i saw you tweet
something that that he kind of like
kind of makes you step it up a little
bit yeah nobody don't make me stupid
right of course in my opinion you're the
best live yeah nobody but this boy to me
you know saying he know how to you know
how to perform dog he's doing his thing
yeah man
he ain't he ain't biting nothing from us
or nothing man he said he'd been going
to my show since he was 14 you know what
i'm saying in cleveland right i've never
seen him you know i mean but he does his
own thing it's beautiful it's a
beautiful thing man you have had a 2011
man going into 2012 you have not
let up you you know you dropped the
strange land collabos you dropped you
know all sixes and sevens and then the
uh [__] ep
what when you gonna take a break tech
i don't know man it's like they keep on
wanting me you know i'm saying the
demand for like right after this tour i
got to go to canada in september for
some shows then in
7th i fly over to europe to do 23 dates
so
i'm going i'm gonna miss thanksgiving
for the first time you know so i'm gone
man it's like and pretty soon japan
gonna get the calling pretty soon africa
gonna get to call him pretty soon brazil
gonna get the calling you know what i'm
saying ireland gonna get the calling
ireland already called you know what i
mean so it's like
pretty soon you know saying great
britain you know saying it's pretty soon
abu dhabi yeah
hey hey um i love that i love that chris
calico joined too yeah
yeah yeah no i wanted to ask you um what
what motivated you to do the ep with uh
with mayday they were on the bus with me
on the last tour playing me beats for
the first time and i'm like damn y'all
beats take me somewhere else where's my
joint yeah man you know what i'm saying
and uh
they sent me a gang of tracks and i
chose my favorite six
and i wrote it in four days man i ain't
think i could do it you know what i'm
saying that the
music moved me so much
and i'm so atmospheric and everything
man it just came out
it just came out beautiful that would be
your third
well let's see all sixes and sevens was
number three on the charts yeah i think
so yeah and then the other two that you
dropped were top 20. yeah yeah
independently yeah do you ever like
like like at what point i don't try to
do it it's just what i'm saying like yo
it's crazy it's like it's just so crazy
to see the natural progression over the
years man it's like
you are like the household name without
the without the big yeah you built your
own house you know you don't have that
code signed in like that's crazy it's
the fans man growing like a forest fire
man they we put out [__] man that
uh ep
with no promotion right we just put it
on our site and on itunes and it's out
you know
yeah yeah
number one um indeed i said something
that says something about you know
people there's certain artists that
don't go by you know they're they're
obviously because i feel like i have
connection with them yeah there's other
artists that like i'll burn their [__]
yeah no doubt i feel you and your fans
are like yo they support everything
i go i go by rick ross you know so i go
buy event seven fold i go buy outcast
i go by kanye you know what i'm saying i
buy eminem
you know what i'm saying uh
i buy snoop dogg still you know what i'm
sizzling
you know what i'm saying a lot of other
stuff i don't really like that's that's
about i still buy i bought all six and
sevens and i bought
last time we talked man um we did an
interview at the station and you were
saying how much you were feeling uh the
rock the ross album like still oh yeah
yeah what are you bumping now have you
have you checked out his uh his newest
tape no no yeah i keep hearing about it
you know what i'm saying but uh what is
the latest latest hip hop in tech nines
uh
years right now my latest
it's still drake's take care man still
yeah still it's funny because i
interviewed you in boise right right
right before the drake yeah thing blue
yeah and you were like man this drake
kid yeah he's crazy he's still about to
take care of every night back there man
you know what i'm saying every night you
know what i'm saying let's start
starting over my dead body and just let
it go let it go just let it play through
it yeah it's real relaxing man you know
what i'm saying um another thing we kind
of talked about i know uh
uh first thing you had hopsin on your
album very um hobson is kind of he's
kind of
i wouldn't necessarily take where you
left off but he's got that same kind of
underground movement that that movement
supports everything he does man made the
double xl cover what is that like you
know knowing you kind of to be honest
uh that's the first time i've ever heard
obstacles on all sixes yeah yeah yeah a
lot of people for a lot of people yeah i
keep my ear to the underground to all
music man you know sizzling and uh i was
lucky enough to find hopsin you know
what i mean and uh
lyrics lyricists always find each other
of course
and i just thought it would be good for
three lyrics to get together even though
we're from different places me b.o.b and
hopson you know what i mean
and uh
now he's
on the freshman cover you know so i just
did a show with them for double xl last
week last sunday before i don't know if
it was sunday but it was one of them
days you know i'm saying i forgot what
it was but um it was a sold out show
from vanessa double xl and i came out on
a
hobson set his last song and did that my
cycle was like yeah it was dope
i love to see people
like um
giving them a chance indeed because he's
one of the [__] like me that
they're like oh that's some weird they
write them off yeah yeah yeah
yeah indeed
real [__] always shines indeed um
what about uh i know em was supposed to
make the album yeah it didn't happen
what was the song with blind fury davis
was so lonely yeah so lonely um
have you
i know a lot of your fans at least a lot
of i'm a fan of both of you guys
but to me that's always like the one
collab of my man yeah like that's the
one you know yeah i want to see two
hardcore rapping [__] together
yeah
you know saying i got a
uh lp
i'm putting together to come out on uh
late october i think it's gonna be the
official tech album yeah yeah yeah yeah
you have the name for yet yeah i just
can't tell them all right this is a
secret yeah you gotta keep everything
kevin hart knows kevin hart okay
how does kevin hart know
this is a long story
kevin hart knows auntie payne knows you
know pain gonna be on the album i hope
so okay i hope so i hope so get kevin
hart to do a skit i don't know let's see
yeah kinda kinda yeah yeah i already got
it for real because you know he's got
his little like rapid personality like
what his name is like something he's
talking about chocolate drop yeah
yeah yeah he's he's a cool cat man